[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER
HEIDEN: Last time, we
discussed oxidative
phosphorylation, which
is how to couple the NADH
generated from sugar,
fatty acids, et cetera; the
oxidation of carbon as a way
to carry out favorable
electron transfer to oxygen
and use that energy release
to charge a battery--
that is, create
this delta psi/delta
pH that can subsequently be
used by the battery to do work,
including the synthesis of ADP.
And of course, this can occur
at a physiological ATP/ADP ratio
and, therefore, allow
the cell to couple ATP
to ADP conversion to other
unfavorable processes
in the cell.
Now, all of these reactions
occur at the mitochondria.
And I drew, here, a
schematic mitochondria for us
just to start.
Remember, the mitochondria
has its own genome.
This is a vestige of the
symbiotic relationship that
developed long, long ago, where
two prokaryotes came together,
leading to this symbiotic
relationship-- but of course,
the mitochondrial
DNA encoding many
of the key components of
this electron transport chain
and ATP synthesis machinery
that remains in the mitochondria
today.
Now, ultimately, this process
involves the reoxidation
of NADH back to NAD that occurs,
that complex I of the electron
transport chain.
Those electrons are transferred
into the Q pool, which
then go into complex III to
cytochrome c to complex IV,
ultimately being transferred
to oxygen as the final electron
acceptor.
And it's this process of
favorable electron transport--
that is, electrons
moving from a lower
to a higher standard
reduction potential-- that
is coupled to the
pumping of protons
and the generation of
this delta psi/delta pH.
Now, we also discussed complex
II of the electron transport
chain, which is identical
to succinate dehydrogenase
in the TCA cycle.
This is involving that
FAD/FADH2, which can, itself,
also transfer electrons
to the Q pool,
ultimately passing
those to complex III
to cytochrome c to
complex IV, again,
with oxygen as
electron acceptor,
ultimately forming
what is essentially
two different variations
on the electron transport
chain as a way to generate
delta psi/delta pH.
Now I show here, on the
slide, that there's really
many versions of this
electron transport chain,
and another one we discussed
is shown down here.
So up here is the typical one to
regenerate NAD+ using complex I
to the Q pool to III to c to IV.
Here's the one involving complex
II, so dehydrogenase reaction
via complex II to the Q
pool, complex III, c, IV.
And then there's yet a third one
here from fatty acid oxidation.
So this is Acyl-CoA
dehydrogenase.
Again, like complex
II, involves FAD/FADH2.
This occurs at the
membrane, transfers
electrons to the Q
pool to III to c to IV,
ultimately reducing
oxygen to water.
And so the net effect of
these various electron
transport chains
were shown up here
is generating this delta
psi/delta pH, which
can then be used to do work.
Now, the cool thing
is is that this
is occurring, in this case,
at the inner mitochondrial
membrane.
And so you can do work in
lots of different ways.
It doesn't have to be
next to the complex.
You have a charge
across the membrane that
can be used different
places in space,
such as so-called complex
V or the F1F0-ATPase,
which can use dissipation
of that proton gradient
to drive that rotational
catalysis machine we described
last time and, ultimately,
take ADP plus phosphate
and synthesize ATP.
But that's not the
only work it can do.
You can uncouple
the whole thing.
We discussed these
uncoupling proteins,
which, effectively,
just let protons leak
back across into the membranes,
that short-circuiting
this potential.
And that's a way
to generate heat.
Other type of work
we can do is we
can use this proton
gradient to power
the transport of other ions.
We discussed this happening
with ADP/ATP exchange
because, of course,
ADP-to-ATP conversion
needed in the cytosol to favor
unfavorable processes there.
Need to exchange those in
and out of the mitochondria,
so you can regenerate ATP with
the ATP synthase machinery.
And yet another thing
we talked about is
you can use this as a
way to concentrate ions,
such as calcium.
And the mitochondria ends
up being a major calcium
store for cells.
Now, we discussed last time
that this is great having all
of these oxidation
processes-- the TCA cycle,
fatty acid oxidation--
all occurring in the
matrix because it
gives a location for
NAD/NADH to happen where
it has easy access to this
electron transport machinery
and the ability to regenerate
the NAD necessary to keep these
processes going.
But of course, the very first
process we talked about happens
in the cytosol, and
that's glycolysis.
And we discussed how
you can bring pyruvate
into the mitochondria through
this mitochondrial pyruvate
carrier.
Then it has access to the
pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction, which, of course,
generates acetyl-CoA
and NADH in the right place.
However, if you go way back to
when we discuss fermentation,
remember, the reason we had to
send pyruvate to fermentation
was to regenerate that
NAD in the cytosol that's
necessary to keep
glycolysis going.
Now, of course, if we're
going to fully oxidize
pyruvate carbon in
the mitochondria,
we still have to solve
this electron balance
problem for glycolysis.
And as we discussed,
we can solve that
by giving those
electrons to oxygen.
But now you see that there's
this additional complication--
is that these electrons
in the form of NADH
need to get inside the
mitochondrial matrix
or get to the electron
transport chain
as a way to use oxygen
to ultimately dispose
of those electrons.
And so, effectively,
that NADH needs
to be gotten to
complex I, which would
be the matrix in the
way we've drawn it here.
Now, really, the way that
this happens is not direct.
So you don't transport
NADH from the cytosol
into the mitochondria.
And that's partially because
one of the benefits, remember,
of having compartmentalized
metabolism
is your ability to have
different conditions;
different ATP/ADP
ratios, NAD/NADH ratios
in different
compartments because that
can favor different chemistry.
And so the way that you get
electrons into the matrix
or get electrons to the
electron transport chains
doesn't occur directly.
You do not transport
NAD or NADH directly.
Instead, you use
so-called shuttles,
which are analogous to some
of the other shuttles we've
talked about, in order to get
materials across membranes.
In this case, this
is a way to get
electrons generated
from oxidation
reactions in the cytosol--
production of NADH in
the cytosol, things
like glycolysis--
to the electron transport chain
so that they can ultimately
be transferred to oxygen.
And so these shuttles,
or redox shuttles,
actually come in
several different ways
that cells can deal with
cytosolic electrons.
And so these shuttles
also, in essence,
help cells also establish
these different conditions,
these different NAD/NADH ratios
in different compartments.
And so you can imagine that the
shuttles themselves could be
regulated as a way to do this.
Now, there's two
major redox shuttles
that allow you to move
electrons from the cytosol
into the mitochondria, and we'll
discuss those two here next.
These are the two
that probably are
being looked for if you get
this question on an MCAT exam
or something like that.
They're the ones
that are described
in the text as the way to
get electrons to the electron
transport chain.
But however, as we
go through them,
you will see that there's
a couple different ways
one can do this.
They basically involve
oxidation and reduction
of a pair of molecules on
either side of the membrane.
And there's lots of ways
you can do that in addition
to these other shuttles.
It'll become more clear
what I mean by this,
but I guess I just want you
to know that these are not
the only ways one
could shuttle electrons
into the mitochondria.
These are just the major
ways that have been discussed
and are usually
discussed in textbooks.
So the first shuttle
system is something called
the glycerol phosphate shuttle.
And so the glycerol
phosphate shuttle
involves a reaction that
we've already discussed.
So here's our old friend,
dihyroxyacetone phosphate
from glycolysis.
Remember when we talked
about the generation of
and metabolism of
glycerol, in order
to make triacylglycerides,
phospholipids--
remember we described
that you can
take dihyroxyacetone phosphate.
If you use NADH to reduce
that ketone to the alcohol,
that generates this
molecule, glycerol phosphate.
And of course, because
you're reducing the ketone
to the alcohol, something
else has to be oxidized.
You reoxidized
NADH back to NAD+,
effectively disposing of
those electrons from, say,
glycolysis that generated
NADH to regenerate NAD+.
Now, rather than use this
glycerol phosphate and lipid
synthesis, turns out
there's a complex that
can directly transfer
those electrons to FAD
to generate FADH2.
And this complex sits within the
inner mitochondrial membrane,
facing the cytosolic
side of the membrane.
Here's the inner
mitochondrial membrane.
This would be the matrix.
And so transferring
those electrons
to FAD to reduce
to FADH2 reoxidizes
the glycerol phosphate back
to dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
And of course, in this membrane,
you can, in this complex,
transfer those electrons
by oxidizing the FAD
and sending them to
the coenzyme Q pool.
That can take the
ubiquinone, makes ubinquinol.
Those electrons can
go to complex III.
That can go to cytochrome C.
They can go to complex IV,
ultimately ending up reducing
oxygen to water using oxygen
as a final electron acceptor.
Again, this is effectively
another alternative
to the electron transport chain.
And so I show that
here on the slide.
And so we've discussed--
the complex II-- this is the
FAD/FADH2 containing enzyme
is complex II.
Succinate dehydrogenase sits
in the inner mitochondrial
membrane, converts
succinate to fumarate.
Those electrons
end up on up FADH2,
can get transferred
to the Q pool,
reoxidizing FAD to complex III
to cytochrome C to complex IV
to oxygen to water.
We already discussed acyl-CoA
dehydrogenase-- same thing.
FADH2 containing reaction in
there is also in the membrane--
ultimately allows another
version electron transport
chain.
And here's yet a third one
involving an FDA using enzyme.
The difference is is that these
have the oxidation reduction
reaction occurring
on the matrix side--
succinate to fumarate
the introduction
of a double bond
for fatty acid oxidation
and the matrix side.
This one here instead
faces the cytosolic side.
So glycerol 3 phosphate
can be reoxidized
to dihydroxyacetone phosphate--
looks like I have those arrows
drawn backwards, sorry--
ultimately sending electrons
into this glycerol phosphate
shuttle, reducing FADH2,
which can be reoxidized
by giving those electrons to
the Q pool to complex III,
to cytochrome C, to
complex IV, ultimately
with water serving as the
final electron acceptor,
as I've drawn here.
Now, if you notice, if
we use this system or any
of these systems, these
alternative FAD/FADH2 using
electron transport chains,
you don't use complex I.
Remember, complex I will pump
a proton, complex II will not.
And that means that if you
use any of these FADH2 using
alternative electron
transport chains,
you pump fewer protons
into the cytosol.
And so if you donate the
electrons to complex I
from the matrix,
you pump a proton
as you go through
complex I to the Q pool
if you go through the
glycerol phosphate shuttle,
you avoid complex I, because you
give those electrons directly
to the glycerol
phosphate shuttle.
And FAD/FADH2 enzyme--
those end up in the Q pool.
Less protons are pumped.
And this is why sometimes
in textbooks, you'll
see that you get less ATP per
NADH produced in the cytosol
than you get for NADH
produced in the mitochondria.
And this is one of the
ways that you end up
with these accounting yields for
glucose oxidation-- something
we'll talk about in a minute.
But the deeper reason for this,
which I want you to appreciate,
is because FADH2 has a higher
standard reduction potential.
So the standard reduction
potential of FAD/FADH2
is greater than it
is for NAD/NADH.
In essence, that
means that there's
less change in
standard reduction
potential for transferring FADH2
electrons to oxygen as there is
for transferring
electrons to oxygen.
And so less energy released,
less protons pumped,
and so that's why you get
less ATP, if you will,
produced going through the
glycerol phosphate shuttle.
All right.
Next, I want to discuss
another alternative shuttle
to get electrons into
the mitochondria.
And this involves much more
what I was alluding to earlier.
And that's oxidation
and reduction
of a pair of metabolites
that are transported
across the membrane on
either side of the membrane,
effectively moving electrons
from one compartment
in the cell to another.
Now, to understand how this
shuttle works, I have to--
because it's a little
more complicated,
I have to first
describe that there's
a relationship between amino
acids and alpha-keto acids.
And so, what do I mean by that?
Well, here's a alpha-keto acid
that we've talked about a lot.
So this is oxaloacetate.
Remember, it's an alpha
keto-acid because this ketone
is alpha to this
carboxylic acid--
so an alpha-keto acid.
Turns out that
alpha-keto acids are
related to amino acids
in the following way.
And so if I take
that alpha-keto group
and instead make
it an amino group,
this here is the
amino acid aspartame.
Now, we'll discuss
later in the course
the chemistry that allows
you to interconvert
this alpha-keto group
with this amino group.
But that's effectively where
your amino acids come from--
how your amino acids are related
to other aspects of carbon
metabolism--
Alpha-keto acids that are
generated in metabolism.
And so there's one example--
oxaloacetate and aspartate, an
alpha-keto acid, an amino acid.
Here's another one.
So this is alpha-ketoglutarate--
an alpha-keto acid.
And if we change that alpha
group to an amino group,
now we get the amino
acid glutamate.
All right.
To remind you, the three letter
abbreviation for aspartate
is a-s-p.
The one letter is D. The
three letter abbreviation
for glutamate is g-l-u.
And the one letter
abbreviation is E.
And I just remind you of that in
case I use those abbreviations.
But effectively, you can note
that if you couple these swaps
to each other--
that is, if I take
oxaloacetate and turn it
into aspartate while at the
same time taking glutamate
and turning it into
alpha-ketoglutarate,
you can see that that
is a reaction where
all atoms are conserved.
That is, if I turn this amino
acid into this alpha-keto acid
while at the same time
turning that alpha-keto acid
into this amino acid, I have
not gained or lost any atoms
or molecules in the process.
And we will see
later in the course
that these types
of interconversions
is exactly how you run
these reactions to do
these interconversions
between alpha-keto acids
and amino acids.
OK.
Why am I telling you this now?
Because it turns out this
is central to understand
the other major shuttle,
which is referred
to as the malate-aspartate
shuttle as another way
to get electrons and
NADH from the cytosol
into the mitochondria.
All right.
So how does this happen?
So here if you have--
here's oxaloacetate.
This is occurring up
here in the cytosol.
OK.
And if we take oxaloacetate
in the cytosol and we
utilize the malate
dehydrogenase reaction
that we heard about
from the TCA cycle--
so basically this is the reverse
of the malate dehydrogenase
reaction we discussed
in the TCA cycle.
We're going to reduce this
ketone to the alcohol.
NADH is reoxidized to NAD+.
That will generate malate.
And now we've regenerated NAD+
in the cytosol by putting those
electrons onto oxaloacetate
to make malate.
All right.
Now, we can take
that malate, send it
across the mitochondrial
membranes via transporter
to generate, on the matrix
side of the membrane,
malate, whereas
from the TCA cycle,
we also have malate
dehydrogenase that can now
reoxidize that carbon from
the alcohol to the ketone
and regenerate
oxaloacetate effectively
by carrying out the same
reaction through a redox pair
on two sides of the membrane.
Effectively what
I've done is I've
moved the electrons
from NADH in the cytosol
to now being NADH in the
mitochondrial matrix, where
this can now donate the
electrons to complex I,
to the Q pool, to complex III,
to cytochrome C, to complex IV,
and ultimately to
oxygen, just like it
would for the TCA cycle.
All right.
Now, the simplest
thing, of course,
would just be to send
the oxaloacetate back out
to the cytosol.
But that's not what happens.
Instead, what happens is
you turn that oxaloacetate
into aspartate.
This is an alpha-keto acid.
Turn it into the amino acid.
If you do that, you
basically at the same time
turn glutamate into
alpha-ketoglutarate all right.
Turns out it's that
alpha-ketoglutarate
that is exchanged when you
bring malate into the cell.
So malate is exchanged
for alpha-ketoglutarate.
And at the same time, you
exchange the aspartate
for a glutamate.
All right.
So now you can take
that aspartame,
turn it back into oxaloacetate.
To do so you need
to balance this.
So you return your
alpha-ketoglutarate back
into glutamate.
And effectively, this is the
malate aspartate shuttle.
OK.
So electrons from oxaloacetate
to malate, and then malate back
to oxaloacetate moves
the electrons on NADH
from the cytosol into
the mitochondria.
To get that malate
across the membrane,
you exchange it for
alpha-ketoglutarate
and to maintain carbon
balance across the--
and nitrogen balance--
across the whole thing.
At the same time, you
also exchange an aspartate
for a glutamate, which allows
you to basically interconvert
the oxaloacetate
and the aspartate
on either side of the
membrane via interconverting
glutamate and
alpha-ketoglutarate.
So somewhat confusing
systems, but
recognize that the net
effect is moving NADH
from one side of the
membrane to the other.
And that occurs because you're
interconverting to redox pairs
in opposite directions-- in this
case oxaloacetate and malate--
on either side of the membrane.
And that's why what
I alluded to earlier,
you can imagine that
you could easily come up
with other shuttle systems
where you have a redox
reaction on one
side of the membrane
and the reverse of that redox
reaction on the other side
of the membrane.
And as long as you can
maintain carbon balance,
the net effect is moving
electrons across the membranes
from one compartment to another.
And that is a way to allow
you to generate NADH that's
now in the matrix,
which has access
to complex I of the
electron transport chain
as we discussed
now several time.
All right.
Now we're ready to go through
and discuss the accounting
that you see--
the accounting that comes up all
the time that is in textbooks
and perhaps you memorized
from previous classes
about how the ATP yield
works for different pathways.
So hopefully it's
clear to you by now
that these numbers that
you get are estimates.
And that's because there
is no direct relationship
between NADH or FADH to NATP.
These interconversions occur
via oxidative phosphorylation,
these electron transport
chains, delta psi/delta pH.
And so all of these
estimates take
into account various
assumptions about how efficient
the electron transport chain
is, oxidative phosphorylation
works, bounded, of
course, by the change
in standard reduction potential,
what's the free energy released
from that?
What's the free energy
to synthesize ADP to ATP.
Of course, those
require assumptions.
And it's, in the end, why if
you read different textbooks
and different sources
you will find numbers
that are actually a range.
There is no fixed number
for what the equivalent is
of an ATP for an NADH.
And that's because it really
depends on several variables.
So let's go through what
those variables are,
because if we can
understand that,
you really understand
how this system works.
So the first variable--
at least if we're talking
about something like glucose,
where we generate
NADH in the cytosol,
we have to consider
the redox shuttles.
And hopefully you appreciate
now that you have this need
to regenerate NAD in the cytosol
to keep glycolysis going.
You got to get those electrons
somehow to the electron
transport chain.
And I just described for you two
different ways you can do that.
Now, if I use the glycerol
phosphate shuttle,
I'm skipping complex
I altogether.
And so that's not
pumping any protons.
If I'm using the malate
aspartate shuttle,
well, I have all the energetics
of doing this gymnastics.
But in the end, now I can use
complex I and pump protons.
And so the yield of ATP,
if you will-- how many
protons I can pump to generate
delta psi/delta pH will
be different if I use
the glycerol phosphate
shuttle or a shuttle like
the malate aspartate shuttle.
The second variable
in consideration
is, what is the
efficiency of proton
pumping by the various electron
transport chain ETC complexes?
That's not so straightforward
and, of course,
is going to depend on
a couple of things.
Remember, we spent a long
time talking about ATP/ADP,
and how it's the ratio of
ATP/ADP that was really
the energy there,
because, remember,
thermodynamics is
dependent on that log
of the reactants over the
product's term in the delta G
equation.
Well, that's true also
for the NAD/NADH ratio.
And it's also true for how
high the membrane potential is.
And so how efficient
this pumping
is going to be is going
to be depending on what
is the delta psi to begin with,
and what is the NAD/NADH ratio
or the FAD/FADH2 ratio,
because all of those things
will affect how much
free energy there
is to be able to move protons
from one side of the membrane
to the other.
Once I get those protons
across the membrane,
then there's the
question of how--
and for lack of a
better word, I'm
going to say tight the
membrane is to proton leak.
That is, you can imagine
that to make ATP,
I have to send
those protons back
through the ATP synthase,
complex V, F1F0-ATPase,
whatever you want to call it.
And if some of
those protons just
leak back across the
membrane, well, that's
how we generate heat.
And so how tight
that membrane is,
that is how coupled
delta psi is,
delta pH is to ATP synthesis
is another variable.
And of course, the last one is,
is the efficiency of H+ turning
the F0F1-ATPase, which is the
same considerations that we
already talked about
for number two.
That is, the higher delta
psi/delta pH, the more free
energy that's stored there
and the higher or lower
the ATP/ADP ratio is, the easier
or harder it is to synthesize
ADP.
And so basically,
these different things,
two through four, in
general takes into account
a term called
coupled respiration.
By coupled
respiration is really,
how tightly is oxidation--
moving electrons on the electron
transport chain to oxygen--
to phosphorylation--
synthesizing ATP from ADP?
And so, how tight
or how well-coupled
is respiration to
phosphorylation really
is a variable that is going to
very much depend on conditions.
And so ultimately,
to give numbers
for what is the ATP produced
from various oxidation
processes, one has
to make assumptions
about all of these things,
how coupled respiration is
and which redox
shuttles are used?
If it's something
like glycolysis,
it involves the cytosol.
And this is why these
numbers are made up.
And it makes no sense in my
view to memorize these numbers.
But I think it is
important to understand
where those numbers come from.
Because if you understand
that, that means you understand
all the assumptions and why
the numbers are variable,
you really understand
the bioenergetics
of what's going
on in metabolism.
All right.
So now let's go through
one of these calculations
just to fully illustrate
what I'm talking about.
So let's go through the
calculation for glycolysis.
So if I run glycolysis and
turn glucose into two pyruvate.
So what do we get from that?
Of course, we get
2 ATPs produced
and we get two NADHs
produced in the cytosol.
OK.
So this is the cytosol.
This is the mitochondria.
All right?
We're going to completely
oxidize that pyruvate.
We send that pyruvate
into the mitochondria.
We run the PDH reaction.
That gives us two
acetyl-CoA, which
is a yield of two more NADHs.
All right?
If we now take those acetyl-CoAs
and we burn them completely,
two cycles around the TCA cycle.
OK, now we get two more
FADH2s and six NADHs--
one FADH2, three NADHs from
each turn, as well as a GDP.
And so that's a total of two
FADH2, six NADHs, and two GTPs.
And so now if I come
together, what is our yield?
Well, from the
mitochondria I've generated
a total of two FADH2s and
six, seven, eight NADHs.
And then up here, there's
an additional two NADHs
that are made in
the cytosol, and so
have to access the electron
transport chain via a shuttle.
A typical number that's
given is you get 1.58 ATP
for something that has
to access via shuttle,
or on FADH2, that
would make sense,
because FADH2 is really the
same as a glycerol phosphate
shuttle.
And so if I do that, that
would be three ATP from the two
glycolysis NADHs and three ATP
from the two TCA cycle FADH2s,
because the NADHs produced
in the matrix can generate
POM protons via complex I.
Oftentimes, that's said to be,
oh, that's about 2 and 1/2 ATP.
So 8 times 2.5 is 20 ATP.
And if we had all
these numbers together,
20 plus 3 plus 3 plus 2 plus
2, that is a total of 30
ATP per glucose that's
completely oxidized to CO2.
OK?
So 26 ATP over here plus another
2 from GTP plus another 2
from glycolysis is a total
of 20 ATP per glucose.
That is a number.
It made certain assumptions.
Obviously, if I assume that this
is not the glycerol phosphate
shuttle but instead the
malate aspartate shuttle,
maybe I bump this number up
by multiplying that by 2.5.
Maybe I use different
conversion factors.
And if you read
in textbooks, you
get numbers that
range from 30 to 36.
I think the highest I've ever
seen is 38 ATP per glucose.
And the fact that you
actually see this range really
reflects the different
authors of textbooks,
or whoever writes these things,
makes different assumptions
about all of these
things over here
to understand how to
make these conversions.
But the important thing is
realizing that these are not
real numbers.
All right.
Let's quickly go
through and just do
the similar exercise one last
time just to come back to.
I'm not going to go
through as much detail.
But we talked about
that 6:0 fatty acid
that we did accounting
for earlier.
If you look back in your
notes, what we wrote down
is that from completely
oxidizing that fully saturated
six carbon fatty acid, we got
one ATP, 11 and ADHDs, and five
FADH2s.
Remember, all these
are being generated
in the-- all these NADHs
and FADH2s are already
in the mitochondria.
And so if we just use the
same conversion factors
that we used for over there in
our calculation for glycolysis,
what we get is 27.5 ATP
for the NADHs and 7.5 ATP
for the FADH2s, which is
a total of 35 ATP for--
35 plus the one,
so a total of 36
ATP from complete oxidation
of our six carbon fatty acid,
which is certainly
greater than the 30
ATP we got from complete
oxidation of glucose.
That makes sense.
Fatty acids are more
reduced than glucose--
more calories, should be
able to get more from it.
And this calculation
illustrates that we get that.
The typical
calculation in textbook
usually describes complete
oxidation of a 16:0--
a fully saturated 16
carbon fatty acid.
That's palmitate.
That's one of the most abundant
fatty acids in the cell.
This, if you
completely oxidize it,
the number and a
lot of textbooks
is 106 ATP per palmitate
completely oxidized to CO2.
If you're so inclined,
you can go through
and do the calculations yourself
and see if you agree with that.
But the key point of all of this
accounting is that none of this
are real numbers.
And I hope you now
better appreciate
what energy really means--
that is, how oxidation of
carbon by being favorable
can be coupled either to direct
charging of an ATP/ADT ratio
as occurs in the GAPDH
step of glycolysis,
as well as the
succinic thiokinase
step of the TCA cycle.
But most energy
transduction involves
this charging up
NAD/NADH ratios,
or reactions that are
coupled to FAD/FADH2
via these membrane complexes
that ultimately lead
to this favorable
electron transport
from lower to higher standard
reduction potentials.
That favorable
electron transport
can be used to create a battery,
a delta psi/delta pH, which
can then be coupled
to do other work,
including synthesizing ATP at
the high ATP/ADP ratio that
can then be used
by other reactions
in the cell that would otherwise
be unfavorable and allow cells
to basically extract
energy from its environment
in order to fuel the processes
that are unfavorable and are
necessary to sustain life.
All right.
Great.
So thus far, we have
focused almost entirely
on how you oxidized carbon
as a way to release energy.
And that's great.
But of course,
that reduced carbon
has to come from
somewhere to begin with.
And every one of us
learned in grade school
that the energy for all life
ultimately comes from the sun.
And that's, of course,
photosynthesis.
And now I want to
turn to beginning
to discuss photosynthesis
and how it works.
In other words, how does
life harvest solar energy
in a usable form that ultimately
involves using atmospheric CO2,
which gets reduced
to generate reduced
carbon that, of
course, originally
occurred because plants--
or, any photosynthetic organism
has the same issues as us.
That is, to fight
thermodynamics, maintain,
and survive.
It constantly has to be charging
an ATP/ADP ratio in order
to fuel the otherwise
unfavorable processes that
are required to maintain
order in the cell.
This has to occur during
the day when the sun is out
and there's light
energy photosynthesis.
But also has to occur
at night, or at times
when there is no sun.
And so thus, plants basically
stored energy as reduced carbon
so that they had something
to eat at night-- that is,
to keep their
ATP/ADP ratios high--
at night so they can do all
these catabolic processes
at night.
Now, fortunately
for us, the fact
that photosynthetic organisms
stored all this reduced carbon
allowed other life,
like us, to evolve
that is entirely dependent
on photosynthetic organisms
either directly or
indirectly for food.
And so photosynthesis also is
the process that ultimately
oxygenated our atmosphere.
Aerobic life, also something
that was necessary for us
to survive because oxygen is
such a key electron acceptor,
really key to our energetics--
well, the fact that
photosynthetic organisms
put oxygen in our
atmosphere also
was really essential for aerobic
life, us, to ultimately evolve.
And so photosynthesis is often,
in biochemistry courses, almost
a sidelight and
forgotten process.
But of course, it is
really, really central
to how life works,
because no life
could exist without
photosynthesis
and the conditions
that allowed aerobic--
most multicellular
life that we know
of that's not photosynthetic,
including ourselves,
could not have evolved
without photosynthesis
oxygenating the
atmosphere and generating
all this reduced carbon.
That, really, is where we
get our energy from as food.
Now, you also learned
in grade school,
when you learned that life
depends on energy of the sun,
that the process
that life uses is
this mysterious photosynthesis.
Well, as we go through
this over the rest of today
and in the next lecture,
I want you to appreciate
what photosynthesis is.
And that is how life
really takes solar energy
and harvests that energy in
a biologically useful form,
bearing in mind all of the
concepts that we've already
talked about, because that will
ultimately help you understand
how that energy from the
sun is used to make all
this reduced carbon,
this carbohydrate and fat
that is energy that we can use
for later, and also, of course,
allows how photosynthetic
organisms can use light
from the sun to just
power things directly
from that solar battery,
and ultimately, of course,
you should appreciate that
these things all came first.
Photosynthesis
obviously existed first.
And so most of what we
already talked about--
well, we'll draw parallels when
we talk about photosynthesis
to the stuff we already know.
Of course, photosynthesis
came first.
And the stuff you've
already learned about
evolved from photosynthesis.
All right.
Now, like all pathways,
photosynthesis also
has to follow the same rules
and laws of thermodynamics that
were true for all pathways.
So plants and animals have
to follow the same rules.
And so what is photosynthesis?
Well, it's ultimately CO2
in the atmosphere that
gets reduced to carbohydrate.
That's classically
photosynthesis.
But, of course, plants
also make fatty acids.
OK?
This is carbon reduction.
Remember, carbon oxidation
generally is favorable.
Carbon reduction is not.
Delta G naught prime for
this is greater than 0.
This direction is favored.
That direction is
not, which means
you need energy input
to reduce that CO2
to carbohydrate or fatty acid.
And of course, it's the sun's
energy, the solar energy,
that ultimately must be
done to make this favorable.
Now we're reducing carbon.
That means we need
to add electrons.
Those electrons have
to come from somewhere.
And so we're
reducing the carbon.
That means something
else has to be oxidized.
Just like when we
oxidized carbon,
those electrons had
to go somewhere,
something else
had to be reduced.
That was pyruvate to
lactate and fermentation,
or oxygen to water via all of
the oxidative phosphorylation
things we just talked about.
And so in this case,
those electrons
have to come from somewhere.
And those electrons ultimately,
for photosynthesis--
this reduction,
the electrons come
from oxidation,
ultimately, of water,
which will generate oxygen.
And this is effectively then
the reverse of what
you learned about
for the mitochondrial
electron transport.
Why this?
Well, water is very abundant,
has been for all of life
on Earth.
Water is-- obviously,
life depends on water.
And so you can oxidize
the water to generate
oxygen. This will obviously
generate electrons that
can be used to reduce carbon.
And it's effectively the
photosynthetic oxidation
of water to make oxygen that
was the source of oxygen
in the atmosphere
that, really, today
makes aerobic life possible.
Now, of course, the fact that
oxygen is a good electron
acceptor-- we've been
talking about this forever.
This means that, of
course, you might
guess that delta G naught
prime for this process
is not going to be favorable.
To put it another way,
oxygen is a great electron
acceptor and water is
a poor electron donor.
And so, really, the
way photosynthesis--
the magic of
photosynthesis, if you will,
is making water a good electron
donor, because, ultimately,
that is what is going
to make this whole thing
work energetically.
And so you probably could guess
that if these processes are
really about these
electron transfers,
we need electron carriers.
This is true for
photosynthesis, just
as it was true for
oxidative phosphorylation.
But remember, we'll describe
a lot of the same electron
carriers that are used.
But as we described
them, remember
that the photosynthesis
came first.
And so the other processes, like
OXPHOS, that use these electron
carriers, use them
because they were first
used in photosynthesis.
And then they were repurposed
for oxidative phosphorylation.
Now, to discuss this,
I want to first start
by introducing an
electron carrier that's
important for this that's
really a variation on NADH.
And it's an electron
carrier that's found in--
excuse me-- all plants,
all animals, all life,
and is very important
in anabolic pathways
like photosynthesis.
Remember that anabolism,
building stuff,
has to be distinct from
catabolism, breaking stuff
down, for a number of reasons.
We saw this in glycolysis
and gluconeogenesis, glycogen
synthesis, glycogen breakdown.
Remember, delta G naught prime
can only favor one direction.
And so in the direction
that's favorable, it works.
In the other direction to
actually make it happen,
we have to make delta
G less than zero.
That has to happen
by energy addition.
And so now we had to have
these separate pathways.
You also need separate
pathways because that
allows separate regulation,
avoids futile cycle,
and enables cells to match
needs with processes.
And as we already
discussed, one way
to keep these anabolic and
catabolic processes distinct
is by building separate
compartments, right?
It's useful to have
separate compartments,
different conditions in
different compartments
that can favor different
things happening.
However, not all cells
have separate compartments.
Prokaryotes don't.
And you might
think of situations
where you clearly
want to have two
different types of
reactions happening
in the same compartment.
And so what if you want to
both do oxidation and reduction
in different reactions
in the same compartment?
Well, clearly you
need some way that
will favor some
reactions being oxidation
and other reactions
being reductions.
And if you simply rely on
NADH/NAD+ as your oxidant
or your reductant, this
now becomes a problem.
All right?
So a solution is, well, let's
make a distinct electron
carrier for the oxidation
reactions in the cells.
So that's what this is.
Turns out, you
keep your NAD/NADH
to largely favor the oxidation
reactions you want to do.
And let's create a different
currency for reduction.
And this currency ends up
being a different molecule,
NADPH/NADP+.
And you use this as a
cofactor pair for reduction.
Well, what is NADPH?
Well, it's effectively
the same thing as NADH.
But now you mark it
as a separate pool
with a two prime phosphate
on the ADP portion
of the molecule.
Let me draw it out for you.
OK.
So this here is NA--
so if I took this phosphate
off, this would be NADH,
put a two prime
phosphate on, now I
mark this as a separate
molecule pool, NADPH.
A is an adenine.
Remember, it's a nicotinamide
adenine dinucleoside.
OK?
So here's a adenine, phosphate,
phosphate, other nucleoside
with the nicotinamide group.
This here is in
the reduced form.
Seen this now a
million times, but we
can oxidize it as possible.
That generates this two
electron hydride ion.
So remove two electrons and now
this nicotinamide form is here
in the NADP+ or oxidized
form of the molecule.
And so effectively by marking
this as a separate pool with
that two prime phosphate, you
can have a different NADH/NAD+
ratio in cells.
Then you have NADH/NADP+
plus ratio and cells.
Use one co-factor
fair pair to favor
oxidation and the
other co-factor pair
to favor reduction.
And so I want to give
a quick aside on NADPH
because it's really
also NADPH that
can be very important in keeping
the cytosol of cells reduced.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, you remember you
learned from Professor Yaffe.
We talked about proteins
that you can have
these inside the side cytosol.
You'd have your cystine
residues on proteins
be in this reduced form.
And outside the cell, you'd form
these disulfide bonds, which
is basically oxidized cystine.
And so in the cytosol, you want
your cystine residues reduced.
And outside of the
cell, you end up
with these disulfide
bonds on proteins.
Why does cystine tend to get
oxidized outside the cell?
Well, there's lots of
oxygen in our atmosphere.
Oxygen's a good
electron acceptor.
It's very good at oxidation.
In fact, that's what gives
it this property that makes
oxidative phosphorylation work.
And so it turns out
that these cystines,
these sulfhydryl groups, like to
give their electrons to oxygen.
And that leads to these
more oxidized things
outside the cell.
In fact, oxygen is very
good at accepting electrons
from lots of donors.
So if you have iron 2+ sitting
around outside the cell,
oxygen is very good at oxidizing
that iron 2+ to iron 3+.
That's rust.
And this process, in the end,
ends up transferring electrons
to oxygen and can generate
lots of oxygen species,
including oxygen radicals.
And so you can get things
like this O2- superoxide,
ultimately hydrogen
peroxide, also
comes from oxygen
picking up electrons.
And as you know, very
reactive molecules like this
can damage membranes,
damage proteins, kill cells.
What do we use hydrogen
peroxide for in daily life?
Use it to clean wounds,
kills a bunch of bacteria.
And ultimately, production
of these so-called ROS,
or reactive oxygen
species, in excess
can be very bad for
biological systems.
And this is one of
the arguments for why
antioxidants are good for us.
They protect us and ourselves
from these reactive oxygen
species.
OK.
Now, cells, of course,
have endogenous ways
to deal with this, to keep
cystines in our cytosol
reduced, to keep our cytosol
in this reducing environment,
prevent this ROS damage.
And really, if
you're going to have
things to deal with these
reactive molecules, what do
you want?
Well, you want
something that's going
to buffer the damage that
these things can cause.
That is, if these
things are going
to react with lipids and
proteins and cause damage
and you want to keep
the cytosol reduced,
you really want to have
a series of molecules
that will actually, instead,
undergo this process before it
can damage critical
structures in the cell.
And a key system cells
use to do this is
something called glutathione.
So what is glutathione?
Well, glutathione is a
small molecule tripeptide.
All right?
And it's among the most abundant
small molecules found in cells.
And effectively,
what glutathione does
is it serves this purpose
of reacting with nasty stuff
before it can damage other
biomolecules and hurt the cell.
And so by tripeptide,
what it is is it's
a tripeptide of glutamate
with a gamma peptide bond
to glycine and then cystine--
so glutamate glycine
cystine tripeptide
that looks like this.
OK.
So this here is the
amino acid glutamate.
Here's the alpha carbon
with the carboxylic acid
and amine groups.
So you would typically think of
the peptide bond of glutamate
was in a chain as being
from this nitrogen
to the next amino acid and that
carbon to the next amino acid.
But in this case, it uses the
nitrogen on the side chain,
the so-called
gamma linkage here,
to form a peptide bond with--
oops, sorry.
This would be glutamic acid.
It uses this gamma
carboxylic acid
on the side chain of glutamate
to form a peptide bond
with glycine.
OK.
So this is glutamate.
This is glycine.
And then this has a
peptide bond to cystine,
which contributes that
sulfhydryl group that
can either exist in
this reduced form.
Or, if there's two
of them together,
you can go into
this oxidized form.
And so, often, this is drawn as
glutathione GSH in the reduced
form.
And if you have two glutathione
molecules that then basically
form a disulfide bond
to give you this GSSG
oxidized form of the molecule.
And NADPH plays a
key role in the cell,
because that's an
oxidation reduction
reaction in keeping glutathione
in the reduced form.
So if you have two
GSH molecules that
can cycle to a oxidized GSSG--
so this is reduced,
this is oxidized.
On the other side you can
cycle those electrons.
If something gets
oxidized, something else
has to be reduced.
So you can have NADP+ and NADPH.
This is reduced.
This is oxidized.
And so by maintaining a
high ratio of NADH to NADP+,
you can keep a high ratio of
reduced to oxidize glutathione
in the cell and keep the
cell in a protected reducing
environment where you have these
glutathione molecules to react
with other things before it
causes damage to the cell.
All right.
A little bit of a diversion,
but a very important system
that cells use related to
oxidation reduction and NADPH,
and needed a place to talk about
it somewhere in the course.
All right.
Now back to photosynthesis.
Now, for photosynthesis,
this reduced
NADPH molecule's
of course useful,
because it can serve as
a source of electrons
to donate carbons to reduce CO2.
So if you're going to reduce
CO2 to make carbohydrate or fat,
you need this
source of electrons.
Those can come from NADPH,
which can be oxidized to NADP+.
And so perhaps at
this point, you've
already guessed or
maybe already know
that photosynthesis uses the
favorable electron transfer
from water to generate NADPH.
And to do that, you use
the energy of the sun.
Now, of course, if you're going
to do a favorable electron
transfer, that can be coupled,
just like we talked about
for oxidative phosphorylation,
to make delta psi/delta pH.
And if we can use that
favorable electron transfer
to make delta psi/delta
pH, we can also
use it to do other work,
including making ATP exactly
as we described for
oxidative phosphorylation.
And at the highest level, this
is exactly how photosynthesis
traps solar energy
and uses that energy
to both remake reduced
carbon and generates
a battery for the
photosynthetic organism that
can be used to make
ATP or do other work,
provided that sun is available.
And so classically,
photosynthesis
can really be separated into, I
guess, two distinct processes.
All right?
So you have this process
of taking solar energy,
using that solar
energy to charge up
a battery, delta psi/delta pH,
which of course can be used
to generate ATP or do other
work, and at the same time
gives you an electron
donor, NADPH,
that is useful to
generate reduced carbon.
Once you generate, high ATP/ADP
ratio, high NADPH/NADP ratio.
Now we can use that to
be couple to do something
else unfavorable.
And that would be
something like reduced CO2
to generate a carbohydrate.
And typically, when we
talk about photosynthesis,
the way it's often
described is how you
reduced CO2 to carbohydrate.
And we'll do that too.
But of course, we'll then see
once you have carbohydrates,
obviously, it's just
further reduction of carbon
to make fatty acids and lipids.
We'll discuss later
how we can use
those to make amino
acids, which would
allow you to make proteins.
And, of course, we can also
store those carbohydrates
as disaccharides or
polysaccharides, storage
sugars, which is what plants do.
They make starch, they
make sucrose, et cetera,
as a way to store
that reduce carbon
so that they can have
a source of energy,
do the oxidation reactions, to
deal with their energetic needs
when the sun is not shining.
All right.
So let's break down
these two processes.
And so to just be very
explicit, the first part
is basically trapping
energy to make a battery.
All right?
And so this means that we need
to generate delta psi/delta
pH via favorable electron
transport, exactly what we
describe for OXPHOS.
But, of course,
photosynthesis was first.
This would then allow us to use
ATP to fill our energy needs.
And we get NADPH if we set it
up in the right way, which is
important for carbon reduction.
Then we need to use NADPH
and ATP via pathways
to describe how we can use that
to reduce CO2, and ultimately
produce glucose, which allows
us to store energy for later.
All right.
So that is, at a very high
level, what photosynthesis is.
And, of course, this
occurs in plants.
All right?
But perhaps more
importantly, it also
occurs in algae and other
unicellular eukaryotes
as well as in prokaryotes--
photosynthetic prokaryotes,
bacteria.
And, of course,
photosynthetic bacteria,
unicellular eukaryotes, algae--
these really are
the heroes of life.
These are the things that life
started from, and generated
the oxygenated
atmosphere, and ultimately
led to the evolution
of higher plants,
but also enabled the
formation of animal life,
and really anything that lives
off of eating other organisms.
Just a few facts
about photosynthesis
because it's really quite
an amazing process--
and so about 10 to the
17th kilojoules, at least
by some estimate, of energy
is harvested on our planet
from photosynthesis every year.
Just to give you a perspective
of what that number means,
that is 10 times the
worldwide energy use
by all people on Earth.
So if you add up all the
energy that we as humans use
in the world, it is tenfold
less than the amount of energy
that is harvested
by photosynthesis,
by photosynthetic
organisms around the world.
Photosynthetic organisms, when
they do this, consume CO2.
All right?
So that is removing
CO2, the greenhouse
gas from our atmosphere.
And this occurs on
a massive scale.
So this is better than any
man-made engineering solution
that we have come
up with by far.
And I think this
really illustrates
the awesome power
of biology to solve
some of the biggest problems
that face our society today.
So world energy problems--
photosynthesis harnesses
a ton of energy.
Global warming,
greenhouse gases--
photosynthesis, better
than almost anything
at dealing with these
CO2 that is produced.
However, this also illustrates
what some of the problems are
and what some of the issues
are with fossil fuels,
because what are fossil fuels.
Well, they're
effectively reduced
carbon that is trapped in
the ground somewhere, that is
effectively old photosynthesis.
So these are organisms in many,
many, many, many years ago
that did photosynthesis,
made reduced carbon that
was effectively
trapped in the ground.
And so the fact that
photosynthesis transducers 10
to 17th kilojoules of energy
per year and we're using 1/10
of that amount of energy, if
that's all coming from fossil
fuels, that means we're
using 1/10 of a year's worth
of photosynthesis--
and, of course,
a year is not entirely
stored in the ground--
per year.
So that's a lot of energy.
And it really comes down to why
people say fossil fuels can't
last forever, and also why the
net release of these things
can change our atmosphere,
because, of course,
once upon a time, there was
much more CO2 in the atmosphere.
And photosynthesis,
over millennia,
trapping these things
as fossil fuels really
has lowered CO2 in our
atmosphere to the levels
that they exist today,
and how, basically,
burning fossil fuels on
the scale that we are
is able to change
our atmosphere.
So you can view this both
as glass half full and glass
half empty.
It really says
understanding photosynthesis
could be a key to solving
some of these problems.
But it also points out
why some of these things
might be problems to begin with.
All right.
Now we want to discuss first
how photosynthesis traps energy.
And you'll see that it
is similar to oxidative
phosphorylation in
many, many ways.
So it's going to
occur at a membrane.
All right?
It's going to involve a
series of protein complexes
where we're going
to favor, we're
going to couple
favorable electron
transport along a
electron transport chain
to favor proton pumping.
That is going to generate
a membrane potential delta
psi/delta pH.
In order to do
that, of course, we
need favorable
electron transport
from something that is
lower standard reduction
potential to something that
is higher standard reduction
potential.
That is what is going
to make it favorable,
allow proton pumping.
That, when it generates
delta psi/delta pH,
we can now harness that
as a way to synthesize
ATP or do other work, as
we've now talked about a lot.
Looks a lot like
oxidative phosphorylation
and it makes sense.
Oxidative phosphorylation
came from photosynthesis.
However, there are some
really big differences
between the two.
And that is in photosynthesis,
as I've already alluded
to, the electron donor
is going to be water,
which will generate oxygen. And
the electron acceptor is NADP+,
which will generate NADPH.
And you might now be
asking, well, how on Earth
can this be possible?
Because, remember, the standard
reduction potential of NADH
is less than the standard
reduction potential
of our oxygen water pair.
And it's really this
that makes the change
in standard reduction
potential positive, which
means that delta G is
going to be negative,
which is why electron
transport and oxidative
phosphorylation is
favorable and can be coupled
to make delta psi/delta pH.
Now, adding a
phosphate to NAD/NADH
does not change its
standard reduction potential
in a way that is at all
meaningful to impact
what goes on.
And so this is really where
energy input from the sun
becomes critical.
And that is-- it is this light
energy from a photon that
in the end makes water
a good electron donor,
such that all of these other
things are satisfied that
electron transport is favorable
going from lower to higher
standard reduction potential
with NADP+ ultimately being
the final electron acceptor,
such that the change
in standard production
potential is positive.
And that really is the
magic of photosynthesis.
And, of course,
once you do that,
now you have delta psi/delta pH.
You can use that to
make ATP, do other work
for the photosynthetic organism.
And you also get NADPH,
which is an electron
donor for carbon reduction.
And the net result is that
you get this familiar formula
that you learned in grade
school for photosynthesis--
CO2 plus water with light goes
to oxygen plus carbohydrate,
which is, of course, the
exact opposite of combustion.
We talked a lot about how
burning wood combustion is
the opposite reaction that's
favorable-- lots of energy
released.
And so the energy
input here is obviously
the opposite of that to do
this opposite of combustion
and stores lots of energy.
All right, so again,
I want to say why
use water as an electron donor?
Well, because it's abundant.
There's nothing particularly
special about water other
than its abundance, just like
we talked about in oxygen is not
really being special
other than that it's
a good electron
acceptor and abundant.
You could obviously build
systems that do something other
than oxygen and water.
And so there are
extremophiles out there
that instead do
hydrogen sulfide to make
reduced sulfur as another--
sorry, oxidize sulfur as a
way of doing photosynthesis.
Exact same concepts
would apply is what
we're going to talk about here.
All right.
Now, the parts of
photosynthesis,
as you might guess,
are spatially distinct.
That is, we're going to generate
delta psi/delta pH and NADPH.
Those are basically
this electron
transport chain reactions,
charge the battery, et cetera.
And then imagine if we're going
to fix CO2 as carbohydrate.
Well, effectively that's more
like what we talked about
with gluconeogenesis.
That's the chemical
reactions that we just
have to build a pathway
for, like gluconeogenesis.
Now these two things
are often referred
to as the light and dark
reactions of photosynthesis.
And that's because the
first set of reactions
generating the membrane
potential and making NADPH
requires solar energy inputs
or requires light from the sun.
This fixing of CO2, which will
just use electrons from NADPH
to reduce CO2, can occur--
of course, it can
occur in the light.
But it doesn't need light.
So it can occur in
the light or the dark,
hence called the dark reactions.
And so these light reactions can
really be broken up into water
plus NADP+ goes to
NADPH plus oxygen.
And the dark reactions are NADPH
plus CO2 goes to carbohydrate
plus NADP+, which of
course gives us our net--
water plus CO2 goes to
carbohydrate plus oxygen.
And in the next lecture,
what we'll talk about is
we'll go through
the details of how
these light and
dark reactions work.
But when we do so, bear
in mind that we're really
going to follow all of
the concepts and rules
that we talked about for past
thermodynamic considerations
of pathways as
well as what we've
been discussing about how
oxidative phosphorylation
works.
Thanks.